i'm paleontologist sans seuss today i
will be answering your questions from
twitter this is dino support
[Music]
at tokaji sensuna us what's the scariest
dinosaur i think the scariest looking
dinosaur would have been spinosaurus
simply because it had this huge sail on
its back but i think here in the united
states the t-rex is definitely the
people's favorite here's part of a t-rex
tooth the largest tooth including the
root gets up to about seven or eight
inches in length these cutting edges are
serrated like a steak knife t-rex ate
the whole prey we have fossil droppings
of t-rex and they show us that it ate
the meat and the bones crunched up the
bones much like some big crocodiles do
today at rickeydell's ask scientifically
and historically speaking how do we know
what dinosaurs sounded like surely the
sounds the movies have taught us are
just guesses no well indeed they are
just guesses in fact it's quite likely
that dinosaurs were much quieter than
people give them credit for birds sing
but most reptiles don't make much in the
way of sounds except for hisses and
grunts so we think that dinosaurs would
have done things like that but certainly
not this lion roar that hollywood wants
us to believe ev4 n2 k4 us when i die
and go to heaven first thing i'm asking
god is what did jurassic park get wrong
jurassic park was made as an
entertaining movie not as a science
documentary the star of the movies are
the raptors here is an actual skull of
an adult velociraptor the filmmakers
decided that it looked too puny and they
needed something bigger strangely enough
shortly after this was filmed people
found a really gigantic raptor out in
utah and since then other giant raptors
have been found in south america and in
asia so there were giant raptors around
but they were in fact much bigger than
the ones in the movie the movie claims
that t-rex could only detect prey by
motion in fact when we study the brain
case of a t-rex we find that it had very
large olfactory bulbs which are the part
of the brain that picks up information
from the nose it had very large opening
for the optic nerve which is the nerve
that transmits information from the eye
to the brain and it had a very
complicated inner ear that allowed it to
hear at least the wide range of low
frequency sounds so it would have
smelled the actors in front of its snout
and it would have been a very short
movie indeed at emo hair a western how
did the asteroid kill every dinosaur
like doesn't an asteroid hit like one
general area rather than like the entire
world the asteroid theory is a very flat
earth theory there's no flat earth the
earth is a sphere what happened was when
the asteroid happened to impact it
released the equivalent of a hundred
million megatons of energy and this
basically melted this huge asteroid
which was six miles in diameter and this
sent up a gigantic cloud of
glowing material up into the atmosphere
this would spread around the world we
see this even today when a volcano
erupts volcanic dust sweeps all around
the world imagine a world where suddenly
it's raining drops of molten glass
that's what was happening and so
basically every larger animal at that
point died and that's why the dinosaurs
were wiped out probably within a matter
of hours
at most a matter of days at laurenberger
us how do they know what color dinosaurs
were for many years we really had no
idea what color dinosaurs had in fact
people sort of assumed that like many of
the modern lizards snakes crocodiles
turtles it would have been sort of
greenish brown and that's what you see
in all the old dinosaur books however in
recent years thanks to some remarkable
discoveries in china we actually found
out what some dinosaurs looked like and
it was a real revelation we found that
some of the little feather dinosaurs
actually had color patterns as vivid as
those in modern birds there is a
dinosaur called cow lung and it had
beautifully iridescent feathers so it
would have looked like a big starling
with nasty cloth so the dinosaur world
was far more colorful than we were
previously thinking at t6 lee us so why
were dinosaurs so big back then but now
animals are small scientists go a lot of
dinosaurs were big but they were also
small dinosaurs in fact there's one
dinosaur that's barely over two feet
long do you live in an environment was
advantageous to be big for your
particular mode of life and there's some
places on earth where the roots are
reversed often on islands generally
large animals become dwarfs about 15
million years ago a gigantic hedgehog
lived on an island and what's now italy
in other parts of the mediterranean
there were tiny elephants running on our
that would have actually sort of been
nice little pets if we had been around
at that time gods teddies us how many
species of dinosaurs are there i want to
know all of them right now there are
about 1100 described species of
dinosaurs other than birds even very
conservative estimates put a number much
higher anywhere between 2 000 and 5 000
and there may have been even more one
important thing to keep in mind is we
are much closer in time to a t-rex than
the t-rex was to a stegosaurus we now
have classified this myriad of species
by looking at various parts of their
skeleton the most obvious part of the
skeleton is the hip region when you look
at the t-rex over my shoulder here you
can see a hip girdle that has three
bones with the front bone the pubic
pointing downwards worse in the
so-called birth tip dinosaurs which is
unfortunately misnomer since they had
nothing to do with birds you get a hip
region that has the pubic bone pointing
backwards there are many more subtle
anatomical differences but basically
there are two large groups of dinosaurs
the lizard hip dinosaurs also called
soritia and the bird tipped dinosaurs
called ornithischia at lust clouds asks
why did t-rexes have little ass arms
that does not sit right with me for a
dinosaur t-rex had really small but very
powerful arms and you can see this here
on our pride and joy nobody really knows
why t-rex has tiny arms it has been
calculated that the arms were still
strong enough to lift up to 600 pounds
of weight earlier relatives of t-rex
still have longer arms other predatory
dinosaurs actually get increasingly
longer arms which eventually become
wings in birds at solar wings us since
when were pterodactyls not dinosaurs
since ever
dinosaurs and pterodactyls are related
but pterodactyls have nothing to do with
dinosaurs they have a early common
ancestor but they diverged in their
evolution quite dramatically
pterodactyls became flying creatures
wings very different from those of birds
which dinosaurs were mostly
land-dwelling animals and only a few
forms later on evolved into birds which
have very different looking wings
at troopers looks asked the question of
the day
why did the early mammals and birds and
fish like sturgeon etc not become
extinct when the dinosaurs did that's a
very good question and in fact it's one
of the great mysteries of paleontology
it's basically different life strategies
small animals can hide a lot of small
animals are also able to go without food
for long times whereas a large animal
cannot most dinosaurs went extinct and
only one group of dinosaurs birds
survived birds as i just said are
dinosaurs because they descended from
small meat-eating dinosaurs just like we
are primates because we descended from
other kinds of primates we now have a
beautiful series of fossils documenting
all of the stages between little
predatory dinosaurs like that and birds
that would have been recognizable as a
bird to anyone alive today it's very
rare that you get such a nice
continuation of fossils between one
group and a group that it gave rise to
at tree boat paleo who would win in a
fight chimera source or anato titan and
nato titan and camarasaurus lived at
very very different points in time in
adult titan at the end of the cretaceous
period about 66 to 68 million years ago
and chimera source about 150 million
years ago my money would be on the
camarosaurus simply because chimera
got a lot bigger both flowers were
harmless plant eaters and so i don't
think they would have really fought each
other at harry bud cheek earth what was
the climate when the dinosaurs roamed
the world in which dinosaurs lived was
generally a fairly warm one however at
high latitudes where the sun would
disappear for months at a time it would
have been quite cold and we actually
have even evidence from fossil salts
that there were permafrost salts in some
areas yet dinosaurs lived there
dinosaurs really could cover almost any
environment that you can imagine we know
dinosaurs that live essentially under
sub-polar conditions we know dinosaurs
that lived in really tropical regions we
know dinosaurs that lived in deserts so
basically in a warm period of geological
history they were everywhere at udonis
haslam 69 us
how are fossils a thing don't those beep
just disintegrate well fossils are a
thing they're real three-dimensional
objects here's a limb bone of an ostrich
mimic dinosaur that's about 90 million
years old basically what happens is
after death minerals infiltrated this
bone from the ground water around it and
they contained a lot of iron that's why
it has this yellowish-brown color and
gradually filled in all of the spaces in
the bone sometimes the actual bone is
still pretty much preserved but in most
cases the bone has changed just ever so
slightly so that it's no longer possible
for instance to extract biomolecules
like dna from it at the arc 315 asks
what dinosaur feathers dinosaur scale or
did they have a lot of bird-sized
feathers the really gigantic dinosaurs
by and large did not have feathers we
only know one really large tyrannosaur
from china that lived in a very cold
environment and had feathers most of the
dinosaurs that we know that had feathers
were animals up to maybe five or six
feet in length and they had bird sized
feathers and we know this because the
bones have little bumps on them and you
can see them when you take a chicken
apart they're called quill notes and
that's where the large flight fells in a
bird insert at mr soak us idea what was
the smartest dinosaur like would they
have used tools build shelter how much
could they understand about the world
some of these little predatory dinosaurs
have really large brains they have the
sort of bulging area here much like you
would see on a bird's skull so these
little dinosaurs probably had cognitive
abilities similar to those that we see
today in hogs owls and particularly in
crows and ravens crows and ravens have
repeatedly shown their ability to solve
relatively complex problems and some
birds have sort of minimal kinds of tool
use as well and something like that is
not beyond the possibility for these
early dinosaurs as well at biolog from
hell us
when did the first humans discover that
they were dinosaurs i really want to
know how we first figured out giant
giant giant dinosaurs robed the earth
the first record that we know of a
definitive dinosaur is from the 17th
century in england when robert klotz
described a part of a thigh bone he
didn't know what to make of it he
compared it to giants of legend
president thomas jefferson couldn't
conceive of the fact that animals had
gone extinct even though he found
fossils of extinct animals on his estate
in virginia he
thought that these animals still existed
somewhere alive out west and that was
one of the reasons he sent the lewis and
clark expeditions out the smithsonian
got into the dinosaur business early in
the 20th century and here's an old
photograph this was taken in the 1930s
an excavation in progress and you see
people here chipping out large blocks of
rock that have bone in them and then are
taken back to the laboratory where the
actual excavation begins we can glue it
back together clean its surface and
ultimately it's ready for study and
exhibit at half past stoned us who comes
up with these dinosaur names like what
if a dinosaur were named hank why do you
gotta make names so complicated the
scientists who described the dinosaurs
come up with the names each animal has a
genus
and a species name and in the case of
dinosaur names it's the same it's
tyrannosaurus rex in that case it's
actually one of the best names ever
chosen for a dinosaur because the
researcher wanted to portray it as the
tyrannical creature that ruled its
ecosystem and because of its big size it
was called rex which means king i've
been very fortunate that somebody named
dinosaur for me there's an animal called
han sousa which is a little bone-headed
dinosaur which i sort of take at a
backhanded compliment that i'm born at
it but it's a nice thing because it kind
of immortalizes you ed mark bessen asks
how did t-rex sleep like curled up
roosting like a chicken asking for a
friend t-rex presumably crouched down
just like a lot of birds do when they're
resting however we actually have found
dinosaurs that were preserved in boros
where they presumably were sleeping or
at least hanging out and some of them
are kind of curled up at paul garcia nba
asks how did the brontosaurus weigh 23
tons when it only ate plants you have to
imagine that these dinosaurs probably
spent every waking minute eating the
other reason that brontosaurus is so big
is if you eat plants you have a big
problem much of the plant food that
animals and people eat is made out of
cellulose and so you need a very large
gut to accommodate bacteria and other
microorganisms that can break the
cellulose down into fatty acids and in
sugars like glucose that the host animal
can actually digest so in order to be a
full-time plant eater you need a really
large gut ed allen elegant asks were
dinosaurs cold-blooded or warm blooded i
genuinely have no clue well this has
been a matter of scientific debate for
many years but we now think that
dinosaurs have a mixture of body
temperature strategies the little
feathered dinosaurs were warm-blooded
much like the descendants birds but some
of the really large dinosaurs actually
were either warm-blooded or cold-blooded
because when you have a really large
body mass and live in a warm climate it
doesn't really matter either way at r 3
i k o x us how long did the dinosaurs
live for weren't they around for like a
million years or something well
dinosaurs as a group first show up 230
million years ago most dinosaurs went
extinct 66 million years ago and of
course their descendants birds who are
also technically dinosaurs fix this to
the present day we don't know much about
individual dinosaurs lifespan in the
case of the t-rex we have found now that
the oldest known and largest t-rex was
only about 30 years old when it died
these dinosaurs grew apparently at an
amazing pace early on and sort of died
young and left in some cases a
good-looking corpse so those are all the
questions for today i really enjoyed
seeing all of them and seeing the level
of interest in dinosaurs out there thank
you for watching dinosaur support
[Music]